[Musique]
il a eu sa première paire de en pleine
adolescence et depuis ne les a jamais
quitté enfin façon de parler bien sûr du
coup Samuel dijou s'est forgé un style
super aérien qui force les
applaudissements à chacun de ses
passages alors ça fait à peu près 16 ans
que jeis dire j'ai commence à l'âge de
15 ans c'est une passion avant tout
c'est l'esprit libre c'est l'écologie
c'est plein de choses comme ça et les
sensations
surtout les sensations il y en a
plusieurs il y a des sensations de
vitesse il y a la sensation
d'équilibre la sensation de glisse la
sensation qu'on all les être en bas
c'est enfin c'est assez divers dans les
sensations on se retrouve enfin il y a
plein pas mal de sensations différentes
en
[Musique]
fait
faut souvent faire c'est un sport faut
pas faut pas négliger c'est pas on en
fait pas de temps en
temps faut se protéger au départ je sais
que j'ai fait ça non protégé mais je
suis entre guillemets je contrôle ce que
je fais et j'ai l'habitude je sais
tomber je sais comment tomber
sinon sinon je
au début il faut se protéger c'est
l'essentiel avoir un bon sens de
l'équilibre on peut aussi travailler son
équilibre et voilà bah ça prend plein de
plein de choses sur soi ça prend se
dépasser et c'est un très bon sport que
que je conseille à tout le monde j'ai
appris aussi que c un sport les plus
complet donc mieux que la marche la
course le vélo c'est ce qui muscle ça
muscle tous les T les tous les muscles
du corps
[Musique]
voilà